I like it actually it's just kind of
like it's not I love skid-row you love
it yeah oh you've been down here no
longer than anyone that half where were
you hanging out before I was in San Jose
and then um deficit school and just hang
out by the beach are you from New York
originally
yeah New York yeah were you homeless in
New York as well for a little bit yeah I
used to chill in Brooklyn Prospect
Heights did you at one point have a job
and like I can't run raised for a bit
sort of I mottled you're a nurse right
you know maybe a few weeks can okay I'm
on fashion fashion modeling as a manner
as a woman or as a woman it's a woman
yeah I prefer you know I prefer
identified female so I had like I
wouldn't do any male modeling presently
okay yeah I'm great so you've been here
for a few years and do you play around
with drugs we talked about this brief
yeah I do yeah I do drugs what are your
favorites uh I'm doing a methamphetamine
cocaine LSD 2cb and cigarettes what's
your favorite fashion hey guys
cigarettes cigarettes cigarettes Molly
meth cocaine 2cb LSD cool and where do
you sleep at night
aside of the road blanket yes they are
here anywhere you nice times did you get
you get hassles at all just cuz you're
very fortunate not to have a portion or
two I try to keep to myself I do my
thing I do my thing I do my own thing
but finds people gave us as if it was
just almost my time alone and it's a
[ __ ] ton of fun I never really liked
being alone and you know being a
vagabond or being a Voyager I kind of
like I wasn't really a wanderer you know
I just a love walking around like taking
long walks but when that's like your
entire life there's so much pleasure in
it you know what I mean I never thought
I could have that yeah it's a very very
interesting neighborhood I love ski I
[ __ ] love skid row skid row looks
like probably like my favorite
neighborhood you know outside of like
you know like Beverly Hills like
kind of thing about I say skid-row
Melrose Beverly Center Monica Venice
Venice is like yours in that movie uh
what was it uh you know you know the
second value of it rolls Beyond the
Valley of the dolls there was only a
gentle people never saw it
you should see it although I think
before the first one but the second one
has he shot kind of like Enya's Waldo
sorry I'm the realist in a file so
Rebecca have you been in love before
always I'm right now when you say always
I mean so did you ever a significant
relationship a real in a sense yeah in a
sense in who's that with you need a name
I don't want to name them there's a few
people there's one man in particular I
don't know it's not that I don't feel
comfortable talking about it's like be
more specific like love is everything I
love everything I look every one of us
is dry other people I need as [ __ ]
love Skid Row
I love because oh so you seem happy Ari
would you I'm very happy to describe
yourself as happy I'm very very very I
never thought I could live a life like
this I'm in like a in a state of like aw
do you ever get down depressed yeah of
course everyone does you should be
relates to this Idol it's okay yeah it's
fine you feel that way but I find a
pleasure in it's like I'm I feel more
melancholy you know then depressed
there's a beauty to it you know I can
see like there's an art to living
there's a beauty yeah that's they're
different things like a certain senses
there's an ease within it slows you down
kind of you're more pensive you think
more what I'm having was a girl do you
get cold the night sure well I'm
actually very lucky I always run into a
jacket or a bug at some point I call I
start running around you know to me
always
oh you've run to skid row there's always
give me something on the floor you know
during your typical day you'll leave
Skid Row at some point yes quick I want
look I just walk everywhere honestly you
know what I mean there's always a
walking oranges
wherever yeah whenever it reaches me I'd
rather do drugs and sleep you know I
mean eat the grave repeat speaking was
the last time you slept on a bed um four
days ago
yeah four days ago except where we cuz
when I was in hospital you're in
hospital for what is the most boring
thing for like my ankle
what happened your ankle
oh my foot is killing me I can't
interested it it's right ov you twisted
it yeah but then he lost have you had
other hospital visits in the past yeah I
was in LA Sorel briefly I'm for being
suicidal I'm not shaking to talk about
it it's just you know it was a part of
things eight thinking back on it makes
me so grateful for how my days I'm like
I spend almost 80% of my time wanting to
be alive the other time I live when I
had no desire to live it was like I
can't wait for this to be over I was
like I'm so yearning is the thing
anything which is like it's very [ __ ]
great you're to spoil it Simon fashion
show tell me what your parents I don't
know a lot my family last time you told
me your parents died I don't wanna talk
about it you know I don't talk about it
all right
I don't talk about my Tommy I won't
bring it up just be honest I understood
who your friends know your friends
oh sure define like clothes like regular
friends I hear the friends you've had
for a long period yeah five best friends
for ages
it sees my gold beads this is girls
using you don't have a phone or he like
that to contact memory okay my bestest
friends are called Javy ironically
enough and we really rename a Varun sha
housing inversion shop like my bestest
friends so weird little girls
don't care and then they were also
living on the street yes they are
they're just like me they not to wander
the streets with the profession music so
this outfit that you're wearing is
beautiful
thank you it's a piece of fabric I felt
the other accord somewhere like I can't
tell you where but it was okay it's
about maybe a 10 minute walk from when
the Panda Express by the way that's just
some fabric you threw together to keep
making things that I want to find
something new honestly but like you know
having fun yet I could shut up 2/3 all
day so the drugs you use they cost money
burning which sometimes has some pretty
big money how do you generate Sun Devils
on prostitutes sometimes I begged my
favorite thing is honestly it's like the
laziest of the world but like a
drive-through and it's like it's a 50/50
usually got money food I'm like hi can
you spare some food that's a good way to
work like it will help you in a sense
sometimes yes sometimes no if you can
okay okay okay
well he eventually something's gonna
happen you know what it means someone's
get it okay fake just Boop you know some
time for some kind person comes by it
helps you out yes for some photographer
you stumble OH - ugh Fiona next happens
we got a attractive but you know hey
wait where do you see yourself in five
years
working at W Magazine there's an
aspiration work at Dulaney excellent
great dreams are good to have
yes I've had a go at the career I'm
going in a dumpster somewhere [ __ ]
around for a dress you think it's more
like was the strap I knows
yeah seeing some kind of a song about
something and the we're looking for a
friends very I know all that was ripped
at all I think she comes to Nikki for
God may be triggered you Jack yet yeah
he's the one who's that an idea of life
I think okay I have an idealized okay I
got that but would it were your favorite
qualities about yourself I don't give a
[ __ ]
I have great [ __ ] taste I have so
much love within me that like I didn't
know that I you know these are
socializing people and I'm gonna have
[ __ ] you know I do it anew and then I'm
happy right now
but what are your least favorite
qualities about yourself I'm lazy um
sometimes I'm like to south list or to
empathic it's too easy for me to [ __ ] on
myself like I should all myself a lot
you know um I don't like you know I mean
like I settle too easily I don't have
any kind of a I mean like like sometimes
your any but usually I'm just like
whatever like I wish maybe I would like
more like a [ __ ] about big I don't know
and um I'm too proud and just giving up
I give up too easily sometimes you know
but it's better to quit then to you know
like yeah I'd rather quit then feel bad
about winning or losing
I think he knows that I'd rather lose
than win just cause it's like [ __ ] it I
don't want that allowed I want the
recognition I want to do what I do what
do you think got you down here on the
street was it just lack of
responsibility or is it drugs or was it
- fine
it's so [ __ ] fun it's so fun I really
enjoyed it was it was what some ways is
so fun about living on the street fellas
later on the floor ok fortunate I was
given to drive sing some Beyonce and
then I can adjust the modeling I thought
I saw you on Furstenberg
that's your approach because they
research nothing else I'm homeless
person but probably yeah so what were
you delay tonight Saturday night looks
rested in the dumpster
find somebody listen music party
probably look for a house the interim
shop and or whatever the [ __ ] is going
to do whatever comes up whatever is the
funniest thing you know I always refine
like the best no I mean you know there's
coke my very favorite favorite favorite
favorite fire hydrants and I was
supposed you know not all the kids there
you're not gonna start they buy these
jeans are like it's what I want to go
buy jeans go buy that that's it
it's got attitude to happen what I mean
I don't know where if you should enjoy
it and go work get [ __ ] you know
Starbucks or even maybe aspire to be a
hostess at as NK ideally author you know
anybody can do those do between us my
friend 10 I was my [ __ ] light be like
you know the work the great thing going
be like [ __ ] it and watch mother's place
and it's like my mother's place right
over there I wish you be run owners
please
I really please Sabrina she's
can't say you're not fun huh I can't say
you're not fun that's really Thursday
thank you for that I can't say you're
not really like these like you know warm
about you wonderful early-morning vibe
cool claw look Rebecca thank you so much
for coming by again thank you so much it
was a nice surprise to see you it
definitely is I just I capillary she's
run it you write hate every time I see
repeat I see Rebecca at the same time
this is the second time you guys showed
up together I'm certain me and who he's
that the gentleman I was speaking to
outside was I've never actually seen Oh
n who else other than in that instance
that's really his street name is repeat
you know you're gonna remind me in an
irony is like the inverse of you've
heard of that movie blow-up Michelangelo
Antonioni
I don't converse of that just don't say
Matthew McConaughey nothing not that
there's anything well they might be
McConaughey miss Phyllis a Jessica
Parker I've heard men to become Kayla um
Rebecca thank you so much you're
delightful you are beautiful you are too
you